[Music]
it is that safe
dude it's a cava I don't know you just
said it like that oh I thought those are
akunis submitted by Lawson do you know
yours the Dodgers the Dodgers just the
way like Chicanos sake years as lawyers
in eco-conscious couple is looking for a
roadkill chef to prepare their wedding
menu well roadkill is a pretty big thing
in the whole like don't let [ __ ] go to
waste community people are saying eat
squirrel and reco well they'll just pick
up roadkill Jesus I did have a friend
one of my best friends well he was like
shoot the squirrel with the BB gun and
eat it oh if you guys went to a wedding
and you found out it was a roadkill no
zine I'm not friends with those types of
people yeah I don't think I mean in
there yes if they're like you're big and
guarantee there's no disease I'm super
down me too super dope I don't think I
am but I'll eat the sides like there's
gonna be rice and beans with my squirrel
jacket Aryan anyway so fish don't really
get killed on the road what they're
picking them up from the side Salmons
when they die same as when they die they
end up on the such a good excuse like no
raccoon for me I don't even have any
gourmet raccoon raccoon white meat taste
good don't want to try like an armadillo
or try like a raccoon I'm like you all
right caribou no a caribou I think it's
like a type of moose
I'll try everything one of those guys I
have I've had elk yeah but you know you
know oh I don't know why but I was just
thinking about the horns
I forgot that there's a bow I do think
there's I think there is diseases
because roadkill sit there for a while
it's different than if you just fresh
roadkill yeah yeah maybe so they're
going around driving with the cars like
okay that's our appetizer so they
actually did a job like posting for
5,000 euros looking for a chef there's
willing to prepare roadkill dinner but
they have been collecting the roadkill
themselves you know what are you doing
discuss no there's a lot of people that
do that because they don't want to well
some of them are poor
and in some people they don't believe in
buying any meats because there's plenty
of protein because if you think about it
like outside
for Nia roadkill happens all the [ __ ]
time on country roads from the car like
in the in the ground and the asphalt
there's what happens quick to like so
you could just drive up and down and
it's like boom something's killed you
got it you get a fresh kill deer maybe
even got deer roadkill sharing like
squirrels nor there's like the ones
usually it's like it's not it's not
squirrels it's like deer or like doing a
cow depending on where you live right
like just cross well that's someone's
property but it's it's like if it's
gotta be feral creatures like like that
like you're awesome whatever right yeah
awesome
mm-hmm people need possum yeah that's
actually how they got to California
people eat Gator
I think Gators a critter you can kill I
tried fried Gator yeah I think I've had
fried Gator bits it's kind of like maybe
the place that make you good but it
tasted like like a hard tough chicken oh
mine tasted like fried it just tastes
like fried like it tastes like shrimp or
something you're like all fried food
mine tastes like a chicken fish a
chicken fish yeah like imagine like
that's a good description but it's not a
thing like it swims in the water and it
tastes like it tastes like chicken fish
it tastes like a but more more chick on
the chicken side so it's like it tastes
kind of stream like the chicken but then
it kind of has kind of like a fish
flavor your mind is like shrimp huh no I
kind of get it did you like these Jeff
have you tried frog I actually like frog
No well it'll be a lot of seafood all
right Thank You frogs not a seafood that
tastes like chicken fish it's like
chicken texture but fish flavor I think
the idea too is I don't like slimy
things and the Gator just it's not slimy
but the Gator just looked at when they
brought it out you know just look like
shrimp you have mine was like like Gator
tender yeah yeah exactly
if the frog was made like that I tried
it was like it just I just looked like
drumsticks oh those are hardcore
those are frog legs I came out with
scallions that was good so this couple
has been kind of like joe said they've
been eating roadkill for about three
years now in order to minimize food
waste and that's really admirable that's
really cool that cost really big that
vegans you know yet
okay so if they've been collecting
roadkill and freezing it and they now
have 20 to 40 44 pounds Wow of roadkill
eating all the euthanized dogs and cats
it's a lot of wasted meat yeah you don't
think there's like chemicals in roadkill
after they get hit by a car how do you
know is there like a test you can do
this thing does not have rabies well I
mean I don't know I was thinking in
terms of the roadkill like can they test
it like oh he's died does he go to
classes no I don't know about that but I
do think you can like make sure it died
soon enough that's not rotten like if
you know you're hunting and [ __ ] I
didn't they know it's fresh yeah they
can know that but I don't know if you
know how it's diseased or not well I
mean it's the same thing right if you're
out there turkey hunting or whatever and
then you you get it how would you know
if it's sick or not people probably know
oh and then I also my question is if
they're not sure they're traveling these
country roads all the time now let's say
they find a deer that is dying but not
dead
you hit it do they hit it again no not
if they let you go from the guy they
would just shoot oh but I guess put it
out of its misery I was thinking that's
mean but I guess that is more of like a
friendly thing so they have squirrel
rabbit partridge that's pretty normal
and a pear tree yeah so say man I didn't
know what's in putting a cap never knew
so squirrel rabbit partridge deer and
they're basically they call it wild
meats I guess that's a nice way to put
it yeah I saw this guy that did that and
he would have like a couple fridge full
of just he would be like I could last
for the next two years I guess you save
money but yeah he saved a lot of [ __ ]
stuff is expensive but like I think I'm
doing it oh my god why is that yeah my
babies like I know this is just regular
roadkill or this is like what they eat
no wait oh is that a hedgehog I think
it's a squirrel it's flattened its
flattened that's just fun I guess it's
like when you tenderize chicken you know
I flattened and been in the Sun for like
two days
but yeah so they've been collecting the
meat and they're looking for a butcher
it's not good to make a cutlet out of it
in the freezer how much energy is that
wasting No
that's a good point Mickey they should
just be in there blowing it themselves
and like cover it in ice cubes yeah
so for five thousand dollars they're
looking for somebody to skin butcher and
joint the cuts of meat and prepare them
in such a way that the guests won't know
what they're eating yeah Oh money like
what's the normal caterer right away
it's gonna be illegal somehow like
that's kind of violate health laws also
they're doing that because their code
I'm sure you can get catering for five
thousand dollars you can I guess how
many people I just feel like weddings
are so expensive like 5k to do this
scene and as a markup yeah wedding yeah
yeah that's you and this is like a
secret co-op mission with some weird
[ __ ]
you think you'd pay more well and you
have to break health code probably so
you'd like your you're risking your
chef's license or whatever that yeah
you're trying to do good but their
schedule and then even though they
collected all the stuff the chef is
serving it so it's back on hand haul
risky is it to eat like wild meat i
watch i watch this episode on people
that like to save a lot of money and
that was one of my skates yeah they
would
this guy would find roadkill and then
like there's like a whole community
behind this thing it's like and they
believe in never buying protein cuz
there's plenty of protein on the streets
I could see it if it was like a deer but
everything else all the other ones but
even though I don't know how you know
it's disease or not because deer have a
bunch of chicks and they're like Lyme
disease but I mean what's the difference
between what's the difference between
them and a hunter like they probably do
their research I don't know not even
that or even the difference between them
versus a cow farmer like they can do
they're stuck in a cage your whole life
discounsel that's true there's ones
without hunter knows it's fresh meat cuz
he just killed it but like the roadkill
they don't know how long that but even
fresh I imagine they have to have some
disease yeah some people I think it
someone knows nothing geez right I think
even GMO or whatever steroids to plump
them up I think they always give them
medicine to make them sick but I'm
talking about
longer it sits there the more disease
gonna get cause like maggots are gonna
get in there like the [ __ ] I bet these
people are lying even the maggots are a
good thing cuz they're eating the
rotting flesh right so the max the good
thing that gets off that's the fresh
meat you have that can we
like say their names publicly so all the
family members and friends donuts
[ __ ] wedding did the most the wedding
happy I mean know that they don't they
don't say their names this is this is
going down but not until they find the
eco-friendly shell [ __ ] I don't you know
this may get some hate from the internet
people is I'm cool with you acting and
living your life based on your beliefs
right if you're in a global warming and
you're trying to eco-friendly and all
that but I think you have to understand
the actual percentage of help you can
give and then also not to force any of
your beliefs on your friend to force
things on your friends like if I'm very
anti leather and all that like I can't
[ __ ] a geo every time she puts on a
leather backpack like yeah I can live my
life my way purchase what I want
whatever that's cool and maybe if you
know we're real good friends we have a
talk about it and we have a normal human
discussion what normal human distraught
about disagree I even know on the
internet everyone thanks migi hate each
other we have really good talk sometimes
like we're real friends and we talk some
real [ __ ] yeah right we are we are like
that would be a cool discussion to have
with close friends but you can't force
that at your wedding no and why would
you be friends with people that wouldn't
be okay with it like if you leaving it
that strongly if you have people that
are that you need to hide it from that's
all they're doing is that they're like
don't tell them what's in there and at
the end of the wedding they're gonna see
surprised y'all be in [ __ ] wrong yeah
but at the same time if they've been
eating roadkill for three years it's
normal and then I go and like obviously
I know because I got people that eat
roadkill like vegans they don't shut up
about it like if you're eating raw dough
go everyone knows because think about a
wedding like you're inviting second
cousin aunt Suzie she doesn't know what
you're doing that second cousin aunt
Suzie didn't hear from third condom
ating on Brendan [ __ ] Charlie's eatin
road lady maybe the baby nah
no the third doesn't know usually the
first knows in the second the first is
gonna disseminate no wants everybody
family group chat their me like dude
what the [ __ ]
I thought we raised him better how would
you feel if you found out that you're
like son or family member was like just
eatin roadkill's I thought they'd be
cool my best friend was even if I ate a
dumpling and they're like oh that was
squirrel I'm like oh cool thank you for
telling me it's you be okay that's what
this series about yeah I'd be okay with
that I'd be pissed after the fact let me
know so I can make my decision no I
would be cool as long as it's not
something that I'm against morally like
if they go oh I got cocaine in the
dumpling third of my arm man but that's
the same thing they're like gee yeah
it's the same thing but what they
already know that about you like for
example I know you're cool with eating
chicken and then I make you a chicken
dumpling and then I tell you a chicken
after right well no I don't know that
it's chicken because I'm familiar with
the chicken chicken yeah roadkill
chicken it's like when you gave her the
expired pork she just would have liked
to know beforehand so she could know who
was it expired
it was growing some [ __ ] and you didn't
tell me until after the fact that now I
have [ __ ] truck so I just give you
this wedding couple camp blanket
statement everybody like has the same
preference maybe they just talk to them
hey don't you get checkups like you want
the steak or you want the fish before
you go to wedding it's like roadkill or
not roadkill do you want the mixed-media
wild your wild low humming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]